um let me tell you something right now I
just you know how I met Margaret you
know I thought it was comedy show this
is what happened what happened
so there used to be a night on Tuesday
nights on Sunset Boulevard called
Dublin's and they did comedy night and
it was the hottest comedy night it was
cookies yeah Dane Cook and when game was
on fire and I was a regular so I get to
go up and you showed up there oh and you
go I just wanted to meet you and I
remember collapsing onto the pavement
onto my knees yeah and I was I never
thought that that's I would like run
endure in that way I always thought you
know maybe we'll get a job - I don't
know you know but um that's how and then
you'd let me to your house one time yeah
that was nice and and then here's what
made me just cook just completely be in
awe for her she invited me to your show
in San Diego mm-hmm
now when you you know when I do stand-up
I do clubs tops
you know Irvine is probably the top
which is 500 seats yeah she sold out
thousands 5,000 people in a [ __ ]
thing yeah it was a thing right and I
remember waiting I mean I got free
tickles you got me in connections but
like I remember like waiting and like
going in to the thing going oh my god
this is so powerful like I've I don't
know if I'll ever do that but she did it
you know I mean that's how much that's
how much she's killed it you know
whoever Square we had time for 53 but
can I ask her what do you think of Bobby
when you first met him like why did you
want to go see the show like from well
I've been a fan from TV and then I knew
that you were really funny I knew that
there was like so much that I was
excited to see and then I was like oh
well I have to see you do stems so I was
excited to meet you and I wanted to come
and meet you
I love your bodyguard we were in Spain
we were in San Diego a week and a half
ago
mmm and we were at a taco shop and Bobby
was sitting down and I was ordering at
the counter and a girl excitedly hurried
over to me and she whispers in my ear
that's steve aoki right compliment
though I said yeah go say hi did she say
to you is okay we were looking at me so
I thought cuz I walk into this College
this car taco plays they know and then
they had left and ran into her and they
were talking out so I could see and then
she laughed I can see her laugh outside
the window the best tonight and then she
came in she goes you can't believe what
just happened that you were Steve Anka
if Steve would like if steve aoki like
was like eight a thousand doughnuts
right and they've got like a piano fell
on his head right and you mean if he got
come back compacted into a Bobby Lee I
mean there's I'd look nothing like a
Steve al hilarious
[Music]